あ、えーこんにちは、
はじめしゃちょーです
はい、ということで静岡帰ってきたんですけども
えー照明も三脚も全部東京に忘れてきちゃって
今、岩の上に置いて動画撮ってます
いやほんとこの石が三脚代わりになって
うわぁ！
今日はちょっとお話ししたいことが１つあるんですけども
皆さんリュックとか
リュックとかカバンとかって使ってますでしょうか
僕もいつも使ってるリュックがあるんですよ
こちらです
ドン・キホーテで何円かな
3000円ぐらいかな
3000円ぐらいで買ったんですけど
気づいたらもう多分2、3年ぐらい使ってて
で、ですねほんと昨日ほんと昨日の出来事だったんですけども
♪
壊れちゃったーー！！！
うぅぅぅぅーー
はい、といことで壊れてしまったんですけど
あのほんとによく3年間持ちこたえたと言いたい
俺は素直にこのカバンを褒めたい
ピコーン
ほんとによく頑張ったと思ってます
だって
そんなにすげぇ乱暴に扱っていた節も
あるかもしれませんが
そんなにちょー乱暴に使ってなくて普通に使ってて
ドンキで買ってよく３年間俺についてきてくれたなと思ってます
だからもうねこの背中の掛けるこの
こうやって普段掛けてるんですよ
や、もうダメだ
だ、ないんだった
普段背中にこうやって掛けてるこの右肩の部分がもう完全に
ぶちっ
ぶちっちゃって
リュックとしての機能を使い終えてしまいました
ドンキで買った激安のリュックでも
ちゃんと使えば３年間持つんだなってことを証明できた気がします
めっちゃいろんなもの入れてたんですよ
パソコンとかも入れてたし
カメラとかも入れてたし
すごい重いものたくさん運んでも
３年間持ったっていうのは結構すごいと思ってます
うわ、純粋汚ねーな
うぇ、いつののど飴だよ
いや、ほんとにね３年間よく持ったなと思うんですけども
なかなかねドンキのリュックを３年間使う24歳男性
も、いないと思うんで
３年間使ったリュックどうなってるのかちょっと中を見ていこうと思います
しょ見ていきますよ
そんな特別汚れてる場所はないな
中も全然綺麗
までも思ったほど全然壊れてない説あるぞ
一回ひっくり返してみましょう
はい
うわうわやば
さすがに３年間使うとね
めっちゃ穴あいとるやん
えー全然気づかなかった
物放り込んでただけなんですけど
なんかもう
内側のポケットががっぽり空いてますね
でここに、シミっぽいのが出てるんですけど
これ一回中でハイチュウ入れてたら溶けちゃって
リュックの底がハイチュウの沼になった時がありました
え、俺これ待ってこれどこで買ったんだっけ？
これドンキで買ってない気がしてきたな
あ、あ、あったあった
ネットで知らべたら出てきた
普通に普通に同じやつがある
え、なにそんなに有名なのって
何位ぐらいなんだろ
ヤフオクで売ってたんですけど
あ、売れてるわ
あ、落札されてんの
えーすごい
いや俺これどこで買ったんだ
でもドンキだと思うんですけどね
いやどこで買ったかもよく覚えてないんですね正直
いやでも確かにドンキで3000円ぐらいで売ってた気がするんですよ
正直よく分かんないです
もうどこで買ったかも覚えてないんですけど
俺の記憶が正しければドンキで買った激安のリュクサックだったはずです
いやぁもうカバンの中身も凄いし
それよりもやっぱ３年間
ドンキで買ったリュックが持ったっていう事がすごいですね
まあ物は使いようって事です
まあそんなかんやでこのリュック３年間使ってありがとうございましたっていう
しょうもない動画です
まあなかなか３年間使ったリュックがどうなるかって皆さん
うっ、ここももうダメじゃん
ここも穴空いてる
こりゃダメだわ
物も人間も同じなんですけど
いずれは
死ぬ時が来るんですよ
それがいつになるか分からないから
俺たちは
必死に生きている
それはリュックも同じです
僕はこのリュックを３年間使って
ま、特に何も思わないんですけど
まあ、けどほんとに何かね
安いくせに
すげぇ使いやすくて
僕の性に合ってたリュックでした
なんかまだ使い道ないかな
ハサミで切ってショルダーバックにしよう
おーおーおーおーおーおー
おーおーおーおーおー
え、ありありあり
お前、、
まだいけるのか
お前まだいけるのか
エンディング♪